so let's let's go through Steve takeaway
you could use them so he's taken away
the other person will start alright so
the first one we'll start with is
aftershock but first we'll go through
his standard moves that he has on all
variations his common shared his shared
looses his normal attacks are you know
he's a monster made of rock but he's
also a ninja who said he was a monster
you know that's a good way he's a man
he's got this is down for vote we're
gonna know a lot we were watching do
note that means no like when you say
down for all the buttons are laid sorry
for right kick yeah that was my nerd
special moves he has a rock toss a
pretty decent projectile it it's in an
arc and he has a loafer rolls across the
ground which people on Twitter are
already college
I've never eaten a bit of rock all right
now what they also to mention we always
talk about this too is that like each
variation has a kind of a unique thing
about them to make you see which one
they are so forget to see the aftershock
version he is not wearing his mask he's
not wearing his mask and thermal is
similar to kimchi in his variations even
as common moves are usually visually or
maybe they have different properties
it's a lot like Kenshi work
you know they look different or they
slightly do have a little bit different
properties just to separate them across
the board which is a blockable it's
pretty fast and the ex1 hit them on the
ground so if you knock them down you
think they're just gonna sit there you
can do that that'll hit them on the
ground not many moves in the game had
that property so very special he also
has this rock from the sky which you can
use follow them and that one has three
different distances so this straight
punch but you can also change directions
you can hold down overhead that pops
them up or you can hop and it becomes
Papa you can loop to do combos for the X
version you can charge it and it'll have
armor or you can cancel out it then he
also has this Rock attack which you can
hold and then release it
you can hold that hold that hold that
keeping do down below one up do any
outside air one in the cool all right so
aftershock is all about ground pounds he
gets this delayed ground pound you can
activate it and then it's counting down
counting down and then it goes off and
it's a low attack and he can move around
freely activated your projectiles out
not going to know when the countdowns
going so they have to either try to
block it and get ready to block it or
that you can try to hit you because the
downside he gets hit p.m. it deactivates
so you can use that kind of control the
pace of match get them occupied while he
plays this game then also has the air
one which is also a low and you can do
that at any point in this jump and you
can change the direction could you be
close or far or mitt and that could be
good let's say you throw your ground
projectile you jump over it or you can
do it offensively like block a jump in
you can do it straight off a jump in so
you have to flock low immediately and
then you go for your throw and you can
do the TX as well no so you know we
always talk about when it comes to the
different variations what do you find to
be aftershock sort of strengths as a
fighter
I think aftershock will be for creative
players who want to use
kind of like subs to get their offense
going like you know you can put it out
and then rush that do a mix up or you
can use it let's say you're fighting
someone who's doing a really job good
job keeping you out maybe like a really
good character with a really good
fireball you can put the ground time out
there and they're gonna have to stop
doing their fireball because the waiting
or maybe you have an opponent you really
wanted to get him to start jumping and
they're really beating you on the
grounds you're having a hard time
approaching that will force them to jump
or to do something to avoid it so I
think it'll be really good for a kind of
setting up your game here in a matchup
where tremor struggles to get this game
going more of a setup based character
yeah you want to move right on metallic
oh yeah I can probably walk you got it
we'll both do it so metallic is really
interesting because he has two different
forms your standard your gold skin and
his moves get a gold property tool like
if you'd see all the moves look a little
bit different probably the biggest
change is the rock punch it comes a
projectile he has a straight one gets
grounded bounces
it's a little bit slower so this this is
kind of the type of projectile that
doesn't keep people out use it to get it
you can put the projectile out run
behind it now then you see Derek in the
lava skin that is moved you use the
switch then when you're in lava there
you go all of this moves have this lava
property they burn you up you have a
little fire effect and they have
different properties like this move
instead of being too projectile you can
see it kind of stuff or the property you
can turn on right you switch between
gold and lava nice you see there this
quick stand so they don't have an
opportunity to do a wake up attack or a
roll away or lay on the ground you can
just hit them and then run right in for
another mix subject and one of my
favorite things too about Trevor is
actually - it's pretty awesome yeah
we've actually seen in some early that
will go under there yes you can actually
use it to avoid like five projectiles
another think there's quite a timing to
it yeah so this is definitely thing like
when you turn on lava your lava feet are
on roll yes there's no like downside
it's just purely what style you like and
how it seems to match so in my opinion I
think the idea would be if you want to
kind of zone the opponent out you can go
and do go shoot the fireballs
once you're in you know you have the
better
of the quick recent weeks and get this
compost normally it doesn't right okay
so so with this version you're actually
you kind of covered two different types
of the fighting yes play styles in one
character that you switch pretty good so
let's we want to show the last version
right crystalline but let's do it you
know everybody do it a regular match
yeah let's uh suit a regular match let's
do it against I've heard he has some fun
talks with Johnny Cage so crystalline is
I think maybe the most unique of the
three but keep getting the Emperor's
courtyard which is kind of funny because
rocks fall down during stuff - that's
very fresh hmm
all right so first he games this crystal
skin and then he'll absorb a hit you see
he doesn't go into the function yeah so
you know you can do it from a distance
and then kind of run in take a hit and
in the air instead of getting combo like
a jab yeah it only lasts for one hit but
it's a powerful tool like you can also
use it if you're getting this on that
like do your fireball it will eventually
but it lasts a decent amount of time
okay it's probably also really good for
wake up's right like if you know your
opponent's gonna wake up like that's
that's a great second right over you go
ahead and do your wake up yeah it's kind
of weird because you can actually
detecting about you can use it and then
if I get it I'm safe or you're gonna do
what you just said it actually try and
get hit right you can activate it and
bake your basically there and then what
do you get
right and then you can go ahead and then
the second thing he gains is the ability
to summon interactive so long okay it's
so creative and from there you can
actually use it to jump off or throw it
so it has the same properties as a
normal active all it's got people
disability you know you can use its
Traverse or it can use it as a
projectile and what's really cool is we
summons it you can use it too yep there
yeah and it does a lot of damage it's
very very powerful
and also the crystals to also have
different properties right yes the
little power function kind of deal here
he can actually be projectiles so it's
kind of similar moves the other two but
like I said it's a little bit different
in each variation that's totally so when
someone started telling you out like if
you read it right you can just knock it
right off yeah dad you ever read oh yeah
you could sit back and just hold it
until right second yes and then you
could let it go it will not absorb the
projectile when it's like that yeah you
can let it get right you just wait for
and of course you could use bolt at the
same time so you can have the armor out
wall your ankles out
so good I love how dramatic I put in
this piece like has arms out well
wouldn't you be doing that probably yeah
I actually probably push the walls down
oh my gosh so these guns for real